with a huge honor to be the first
ambassador from the digital space
because they've honestly been great
partners they said hey you understand
the internet and how to speak to the
people on the internet so you tell us
like what campaigns do you think would
work and what initiatives do you think
makes sense I've kind of had free-range
to be really creative and my initiatives
which is super cool because I have a
great team backing me up Lily's first
UNICEF campaign is bringing awareness to
a children's helpline in India called
Childline 1098 you can be a superhero
right here in India if you see or hear
something you think is wrong call 1098
toll-free from any phone service even in
my personal experience when I was
talking to a lot of young girls and some
of the villages I visited they didn't
know about it they were telling you
firsthand about experiences facing
violence and they didn't know about it
so I thought okay this is I mean it's a
large complex issue that's gonna take a
lot to solve but I think this is a
really great step for them to know
there's resource for them continuing to
prove she's a boss at everything she
does Lilly has not only started her own
production company but is working on
adapting her best-selling book how to be
a boss for the small screen but would
she star in it I think for how to be a
boss I would like to star in it I think
that one's a little precious to me
there's a few brands I have where I'm
the baby I think I want to be that one
I'm what a lot of other projects that
I'm I'm currently pegged to star and I'm
not Precious about it like I said if I
see
if I read something and I think oh they
want me to star in this but honestly I
think someone can do a better job than
me but I want that person to do it
I want the story to just be told like
I'm not precious about I'm so humble
like honestly really humble yeah